my friend lex friedman recently just had
elon musk on his podcast and i gotta
tell you it's one of those conversations
you have to listen to but there was a
specific part of the conversation where
elon starts talking about
cryptocurrencies bitcoin and money
dogecoin many other things i found it
fascinating so i figured that i'd just
sit here we'd watch it together and i
could fill in a couple of thoughts that
i have around some of elon's comments
let's first start with his thoughts just
around cryptocurrency in general here's
part of the video i think the
cryptocurrency thing is an interesting
approach to
reducing the error in the database that
is called money people often will think
of money as having power in and of
itself it does not money is
information and it does not have power
in and of itself if you are stranded on
a tropical island and uh
you have a trillion dollars it's useless
because there's no there's no resource
allocation
money is a database for resource
allocation i think that that's a great
point by elon first of all the idea of a
blockchain the idea of a cryptocurrency
is to solve part of the money problem it
is to solve who owns what and who
actually can send this digital currency
to other people it's the whole point of
solving the double spin problem his idea
that money in itself is not powerful is
also true i love the example he gives
here in terms of being on an island with
all this money not worth a damn thing
money is only worth something if
somebody's willing to take it from you
and give you a good or a service in
exchange so of course elon one of the
founders of paypal really has thought a
lot about money has thought a lot about
transactions and obviously understands
this to a degree that the average person
doesn't so that makes his next thoughts
around bitcoin specifically even the
more interesting here's what he said
when it started to talk about bitcoin
during the interview there is a
fundamental issue with um say bitcoin in
its current form
uh in that it's the transaction volume
is very limited latency for
properly confirmed transactions to is
too long much longer than you'd like
it's actually not great from um
a transaction volume standpoint or a
latency standpoint
so it is perhaps useful as to search to
solve an aspect of the money database
problem which is the sort of store of
wealth or an
accounting of
relative obligations i suppose but it is
not useful as a
currency as a day-to-day currency one of
the things that i think is really
interesting is that obviously elon is
talking about the layer one of bitcoin
and of course they have about 10 minute
block times and if there's tons and tons
of people trying to use the layer one
it's not super scalable so fees spike
and the wait time can be quite long but
that is true a couple of years ago now
we have things like the lightning
network layer two and this is gonna be
true of all blockchains not just bitcoin
but every single blockchain is gonna
eventually run into the problem you
cannot scale a layer one you're going to
have to use layer 1 for security it's
all about protecting the network being
as decentralized as possible the
scalability is going to come in at layer
2. so if you look at something like the
lightning network you can have
instantaneous cash finality settlements
to those transactions and you can do it
for essentially no cost so the
scalability the low cost the high
throughput all happens at layer two and
it benefits from the security of layer
one i think that elon may not understand
exactly what's going on with the layer
two and he's just focused on the layer
one the other thing that i think is
really interesting is i've talked to a
number of people who were either
founders or early employees at paypal
where elon obviously thought a lot about
money and one of the things that i find
interesting is many of them separate out
the store of value asset from a medium
of exchange asset now in my opinion
actually the holy grail is to be able to
do both if you think of the dollar for
example it serves as a store value
sometimes a good one sometimes not it
serves as a medium of exchange and also
serves as a unit of account those are
basically the three aspects of money
store value medium exchange and a unit
of account now bitcoin today is much
better as a store value than it is as a
medium of exchange but ultimately so was
the dollar at one point the dollar was
backed by gold gold was a great store of
value it sucked as a medium of exchange
dollars were created on top of the gold
as paper claims to that gold the dollars
were the layer two the dollars made it
easier to have a medium of exchange so
ultimately that's what bitcoin is going
through as well we're only 12 years into
this journey and there is a sequence to
the game there's levels to this [ __ ] as
some may say you start with the store of
value at layer one that's all about
security you then build layer two and
that's where you get medium of exchange
with things like the lightning network
and then you continue to go from there
so ultimately i think that bitcoin is
following the exact same sequence that
other forms of money have followed in
the past elon then went on and started
to talk about dogecoin which we know
he's super excited about and we know
that he holds a very small portion of
his portfolio in dogecoin as well so
here's what elon had to say about doge
specifically part reason why i think
there's some
um merits dogecoin even though it was
obviously created as a joke is that
it it actually does have a much higher
uh transaction volume capability than
bitcoin you know like the cost of doing
a transaction the the doj coin fee is is
very low like right now if you want to
do a bitcoin transaction the price of
doing that transaction is very high so
you could not use it effectively for
most things um and nor could it even
scale to a high volume and when bitcoin
was you know started i guess when around
2008 or something like that the internet
connections were
much worse than they are today like
order of magnitude i mean it's just the
way way worse you know in 2008 so
so like having us you know a small lock
size or whatever is
you know and a long
synchronization time is
made sense in 2008 but did you know 2021
or fast forward 10 years it's like it's
it's like economically low and i think
there's some
value to
having
a linear increase in the amount of
currency that
is generated if if a currency is
expected to increase in value over time
there's a reluctance to spend it because
you're like oh if i
i'll just hold it and not spend it
because it's scarcity is increasing with
time so if i spend it now then i will
request defending it stop it there
here's two things that i think i'm
pulling out of his comments around
douchecoin the first is this idea that
dogecoin has higher throughput and lower
fees well the way that a blockchain
works is that if nobody uses it the fee
is essentially zero because the fee is a
direct response to competition for that
block space now at the layer one if you
compare bitcoin to dogecoin nobody uses
dogecoin and lots of people use bitcoin
so naturally the fee is going to be
higher another way to look at it is that
even though dogecoin's fees are nearly
nothing compared to bitcoin nobody is
still using it in comparison from an
aggregate number of users or aggregate
number of transactions the second thing
obviously is that the people who are
using bitcoin very frequently they're
starting to use layer two compared to
dogecoin's layer one it's important to
understand yes it has lower fees but
that is not necessarily a good thing
obviously if it was super popular the
fees would go up and the reason why the
fees are down is because it's not super
popular as a medium of exchange the
second thing is that when we start to
get into ideas around bitcoin you could
increase the block size you could make
all of these changes but the important
part about bitcoin is not only that the
layer one is secure that it's the most
decentralized strongest computer network
in the world but also that the monetary
policy and the technical components of
the actual blockchain are not going to
change what we know is that central
banks need to be both independent and
predictable in order to be effective
there is nothing more independent for a
monetary policy than to be decentralized
no one person or group controls it but
also to be predictable you can't change
you can't have variables coming into
your monetary policy if you think about
in the united states what's the next
interest rate decision nobody knows how
much qe is coming next year nobody knows
but with bitcoin we know exactly what
can happen we know exactly what the
design of the system is and the
inability to change it by any one person
or group is part of the value prop it is
predictable it's a programmatic monetary
policy and that is part of the value
that people choose to understand and use
bitcoin as a store of value now let's
continue with elon's comments some
dilution of the currency occurring over
time that's that's more of an incentive
to use as a currency those coins so it
randomly has
uh
a just a fixed a number of sort of coins
or hash strings that are generated every
year so there's there's some inflation
but it's not a percentage base it's a
it's so
it's a fixed number so the percentage of
inflation will necessarily decline over
time i'm not saying that it's like the
ideal system for a currency but i think
it actually is just fundamentally better
than anything else i've seen just by
accident i don't know how much time elon
is spending on cryptocurrency bitcoin
dogecoin etc he's kind of a busy guy
been super super successful i'm a big
fan he's obviously built one of the most
important car companies in america he
also happens to be launching reusable
rockets and then landing them back on
drone ships in the ocean it's absolutely
incredible but i think that when it
comes to this part of his legacy
knowledge around money his legacy
understanding of transactions and his
understanding of how the fiat system
works may actually be somewhat of a
liability it's limiting the way that he
understands how some of this works now i
don't disagree with him that the ideas
of competition and experimentation are
important in the industry but i do think
that he is underestimating the
importance of bitcoin both the layer one
the scalability of layer two and also
the fact that the network effect has
taken hold and there are 100 plus
million people around the world that are
choosing to use bitcoin as a global
store of value now that medium of
exchange use case that he talked about
will continue to become more and more
popular as adoption increases for
bitcoin because as adoption increases
the volatility ends up going down as
volatility goes down the opportunity
cost of holding versus spending
drastically decreases as well one of the
critiques if i was elon that i would
actually talk about in terms of
preventing more and more medium of uh
exchange use cases is that there's
taxation on it it's not like a
traditional currency where if you go and
you spend it you don't pay capital gains
tax with bitcoin you do same with
dogecoin and others so i do think that
there are fair critiques of these assets
but i think that elon's comments are on
money dead-on he really understands
money he understands what makes it
powerful he understands what drives that
value he also understands generally
blockchains and cryptocurrency he
realizes that this is a database
technology that can help solve some of
the problems with legacy money but i do
think that he's underestimating bitcoin
and i hope that as he continues to learn
more then he'll continue to evolve his
thought process i've got a big big
belief that elon's eventually going to
continue to become an expert on this
topic as well